are you in lockdown on the farm yes I'm
on the farm we had locked down on the
farm and so it's just been so weird for
me because obviously Paul is the farmer
so I've had to help out on the farm and
it's just so traumatic so he's calling
you out to do actual farming things yeah
this is the longest I've been down here
I mean anyone who knows I just assume on
a farm I'd be like snow why you know the
animals would come out birds would land
on my finger but it's just like septic
teeth and mange season so I'm actually
helping with lambing know you've sent us
a video is that of you helping with the
lambing it's cold
massaging it aids ascetic teens because
thanks for sending us this I'm really
looking forward to it you say so it's
like the land couldn't suckle at the
mums change but it was blocked so you
have to massage it to get the milk out
is that what Paul told you the poor
sheep one of them was full one of the
other but is that what you call a sheet
other thing I don't know so we had to
massage it thank you thank you dr. Carr
and basically I'm using this as an
audition for Countryfile
you failed next
[Music]
you